an estimated 115 million Americans plan
to shop today in stores and online
shoppers across the country are lining
up this morning hoping to get the best
Black Friday deals
customers will find deep discounts today
on televisions tablets and appliances
our Michelle Miller is at a Best Buy in
Secaucus New Jersey where some deals
were sold out before the doors even
opened last night Michelle good morning
that is so true Vlad good morning well
this Best Buy it got stocked restocked
and it's ready to go this morning for
the next round of Black Friday shoppers
when they walk in here this morning in
about an hour now when this Thanksgiving
weekend is all said and done it's
estimated that nearly 70 percent of
Americans will have either walked in and
shopped in stores or online with the
holiday shopping season in full swing
millions are on the hunt today for the
best bargains you miss turkey day
Vanessa Cuevas and Rachel Palumbo began
waiting in line at this New Jersey Best
Buy
Wednesday night is that a deal together
they saved six hundred and forty dollars
that's about $35 for every hour they
spent waiting in line there are high
hopes for this holiday season
Charisse Jones is a national business
correspondent for USA Today what can we
expect in retail sales this Black Friday
is consumer confidence just gangbusters
what are we expecting unemployment has
dropped and so people are really
thinking that folks are gonna head to
the stores and head online this season
in 2015 this was Black Friday at a
Walmart in Northeast El Paso Texas the
days of brawling over TVs may be
numbered though as many opted to shop
online Amazon alone is expected to take
half of the holiday season sales growth
by Thanksgiving night consumers had
already spent 1.5 billion dollars on
line that's up about 17 percent from
last year
Toys R Us which declared bankruptcy
earlier this year
is trying to keep up the holiday season
is extraordinarily important executive
vice president Richard Berry says they
started planning for this Black Friday
more than a year ago we have massive
stores that are able to bring brands and
products to life you can't do that
online
another boost is expected for small
businesses of course it's Small Business
Saturday
tomorrow and then the ever-popular
online retail of cyber monday viana you
know what I'm just so happy that we
didn't see fights in that piece you know
usually used to start out after the
Thanksgiving holiday people beating each
other up for that thing you know gift
and we didn't see that so people are
shopping respectfully at least this
morning Michelle thanks